Surinder the old father demands it no we
only really get to see a handful of
North Scots in a new god of war but two
of those are the sons of thor Modi and
Magni like with so many of my God of all
videos this video most likely contains
spoilers so if you haven't played
through the story yet
or you just don't want to be spoiled
then please click away now most of what
we see regarding the brothers is unique
to the game as mentions of Modi and
magnet in Norse mythology are quite
scarce both Modi and Magnezone to be
quite aggressive in hostile towards
pretty much anyone including crater sand
at Reyes and considering how
temperamental Thor Assurant to be it's
no surprise that his sons would only
follow in his footsteps Modi and Magnus
worse one of the major boss fights in
the game and after quite a brutal scene
Magne is killed with modi fleein only to
be blamed by thor for his brother's
death after several more encounters of
modi he would also eventually be killed
this time by at Reyes in-game we see
that Magna possesses a great deal of
strength and both Modi and Magna capable
of harnessing the power of lightning a
power that is never really alluded to in
their mentions of Norse mythology the
biggest difference between Modi and
Magni in God of War and Norse mythology
is that the brothers were actually part
of the few survivors of Ragnarok where
they would eventually inherit their
father's hammer Mjolnir and this does
seem very unlikely in game now with them
both being dead and all the only other
story that involves the sons of Thor is
the one that is mentioned by Mamiya
during one of you spoke journeys and
involves a giant room near when Thor
swung his hammer at the Giant smashing
his head into pieces
cruelly I fell on top of Thor pinning
him to the ground
Thor unable to move the giant called for
help from the other gods who despite
their best effort could not budge from
his body when Thor son Magni saw his
father in distress despite only been
three nights old the child came to
Thor's aid lifting a giant with ease
although this story only features Magni
it does show us the potential for sons
it's because of this story that we see
Magni is being portrayed as extremely
strong with the constant desire to fight
and demonstrate his strength this does
also create quite an interesting dynamic
between the two brothers in game as the
great feat of lifting the giant was
performed by Magni we see modi as almost
living in the shadow of his brothers
great achievement this becomes somewhat
apparent when we see Modi confront
Kratos telling him that he earned his
father's hammer but because Magni is
dead everyone will assume that is the
early reason he was given me or Nia as a
result of this Modi comes across as
cruel bitter and resentful trying
extremely hard to impress his father
this may not be something that has ever
mentioned in Norse mythology but it's
not too difficult to imagine that years
of living in Magni shadow could have
shaped Modi into the person we see in
God of War Modi's and make these names
were thought to mean brave and great
embodying features associated with their
father but that isn't exactly what we
see in the game especially with Modi I'm
sure anyone who has played or watched
the game was not particularly sad to see
the back of Modi in Magni but as always
feel free to share any thoughts on Modi
and Magni and if you have any
suggestions for future videos then let
me know in the comments below